so is it difficult or frustrating or do
you get a kick out of the idea that
you're part franchise where you kind of
can't talk about anything that happens
it's so important to the story yeah I
mean it's it's tricky when you're in
interviews and you can't I mean yeah
that's I mean it's kind of fun because
it's like Christmas you know when you
get you get people that you care about
gifts that you really think they're
gonna love and then you're like oh I've
got these goods and I get that feeling
is so wonderful mm-hmm
yeah you really just don't want to don't
don't ruin Christmas the fan theories go
really deep with these movies do you
feel me do you keep up at all with any
of them
I heard a couple yeah I heard some
interesting ones yeah did you yeah
Quentin Kowalski
Quentin Kowalski the Quidditch player
right yeah his name sound familiar to
you
well yeah but part of your name and part
of my name Oh Quentin yeah yeah I want
to do a little thing with you a little
bit like a confirm or deny okay but
we're doing a little bit differently so
if there's truth to this fan theory
you'll say Lumos okay if there's not
what was that there was a carbonyl
Munchkin fantastic yeah if there's no
truth pay no attention
well now that's all I'm obsessed about
it that's all I want to see is that tent
has to be the carbuncle munchkin
carbuncle munchkin what's that even look
like you say it three times fast and
it'll show up if we do it together
yeah carbuncle munchkin if there's truth
Lumos if there's not ridiculous and if
no comment expelliarmus
okay so newt is actually ultimately
working for Arianna Dumbledore to get
answers about the obscure eels
maybe I should give you a fourth option
like what yeah question question
credence and leader are Grindelwald kids
[Laughter]
okay okay I just like the other thing
Queenie
actually ends up with Grindelwald I
don't know expelliarmus and this is this
is part of what it's like like the idea
that you just can't say anything and
fans are just rabid about it online
right yeah well also you have to
understand though that we don't know the
whole we don't know the whole arc so
like we know what happens in this film
but next film could be something totally
different exactly I see all right well
thank you so much sorry we said nothing
[Laughter]